[Musique]
belga
rideau
je me sens
un bon niveau
[Musique]
à des milliers de kilomètres de kiev ont
brandi le drapeau russe dans les rues de
bangui capitale de la centrafrique une
ancienne colonie française
[Musique]
si les russes ont demandé à l'ukraine
d'arrêter ces attaques mais les
ukrainiens n'ont pas obéi alors la
russie a attaqué l'ukraine c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre
ces manifestations sont organisées par
une association anti françaises aient
financé par les russes
la russie a dans notre aperçu au moins
difficile nous sommes obligés de lui
apporter un soutien moral et cette
manifestation c'est juste pour lui
démontrer par a plus b que en tout cas
l'actrice sud-africaine le soutien le
soutien à tous les niveaux
en allié russe indispensable en
centrafrique
un pays déchiré par des décennies de
guerre civile qui bascule à nouveau dans
la violence l'an dernier
le gouvernement menacé par des rebelles
qui encercle la capitale mobilise toutes
les forces à sa disposition vous
défendez le pays vous défendez la nation
contre les rebelles et les mercenaires
vous le devez cédé aucun centimètre de
notre territoire national
vous avez tous nos encouragements et
soutient propos
aux côtés de l'armée centrafricaine
on aperçoit désormais des hommes blancs
le visage toujours masqué sous couvert
dans l'accord de défense avec moscou des
milliers de combattants russes
débarquent en centrafrique des
mercenaires opérant pour le compte de la
société wagner une armée de l'ombre au
service du kremlin sans existence légale
bonjour
[Musique]
en centrafrique il assure même la
protection rapprochée du président de la
république faustin archange touadéra
[Musique]
sur le continent moscou pousse ses pions
au détriment de l'influencé française
dans les grandes cérémonies fleurissent
des drapeaux russe sur des chars offert
par le kremlin les musiciens de moscou
célèbre même cette alliance
la propagande se met en marche et la
russie est à la manoeuvre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an plus tard l'armée ses alliés
russes ont repoussé les rebelles hors
des villes
à bangui les activités reprennent
les mercenaires eux sont toujours là et
se font plus discret presque
insaisissable il fuit les caméras
dans l'unique université du pays les
étudiants font leur première rentrée
après la guerre
parmi eux 13 heures à doom il achève sa
licence de droit
mais c'est surtout l'un des plus
virulents défenseurs de l'intervention
russe
l'instabilité et est le fruit elle vous
idée travail abattu par nos allées et
quand je parle de nous aller je parle de
la france et russe
donc ces passages puisqu'elle a déjà une
sécurité et de la stabilité nous nous
avons l'espoir que nos petits frères
venus étudier dans les meilleures
conditions
après ses cours trésor s'arrête aux
portes de l'université
[Musique]
ici les rues sont érigée en monument à
la gloire de leurs combattants
vous avez une femme avec ses enfants
derrière et vous avez les militaires
devant sa part déjà sa part déjà te
donne déjà une vue générale sur la
sécurisation de la population civile et
ses militaires s'ils sont les faca et
les russes moi quand je vois ça je vois
l'espoir aujourd'hui c'est pour une
maman aujourd'hui c'est pour de deux
enfants trois enfants demain ça sera mon
tour et vont protéger et moi du coup
quand je vois ça je suis rassuré cuyala
ce christ jésus rassurez-vous contre
attaquer ils seront là pour me protéger
donc quand je vois ça j'ai la joie j'ai
la gratitude et je les applaudis pour
tout ce qu'ils ont fait
[Musique]
l'espoir suscité par l'arrivée des
russes en centrafrique sans racines dans
le passé tragique et sanglant du pays et
de ses 5 millions d'habitants pris dans
une guerre civile interminable est
jalonnée de massacre
[Musique]
bangui porte encore les stigmates de ces
affrontements
dans le quartier de trésors sur le bord
de la route reposent les corps de
dizaines d'habitants victimes des
milices en 2013
ici vous avez
cessé depuis le goût là bas jusqu'ici
donc on a un deux trois quatre cinq
tombeau a cédé 6 mitchell la population
civile et ceux qui ont été tués par les
rebelles à chaque fois que je viens là
je m'incline ça ça nous rappelle
toujours nos frais temps perdu leurs
vies nos soeurs qui ont perdu la vie
pendant ces élus membres douloureux à un
moment on pouvait pas traverser la route
à un moment il ya des secteurs où on
peut pas on peut pas mettre pied parce
que c'était occupez pas papa les
rebelles et donc forcément j'ai vu qu'au
aussi beaucoup de choses
les cicatrices de 2013 à peine refermée
la population redoute un nouveau
désastre huit ans plus tard les rebelles
étaient de retour aux portes de la ville
juste derrière ces collines
il était aisé de ce côté là il y en
avait même qui était déjà dans la
capitale mais qui s'étaient déguisés en
civils mais avec l'appui de nos alliés
naturellement les russes et les rondeurs
et ils ont été repoussés et le pays est
en pole au mans est repoussé mais
jusqu'au fin fond du du pays et donc ça
nous donne un espoir
ne plus revivre l'enfer après des
décennies de chaos le pays est à terre
l'économie à bout de souffle et la
majorité des centrafricains ne mange pas
à sa faim
dans le monde meilleur
pas
dans ces quartiers de bangui ragno le
sentiment d'être abandonnés par la
france l'ancienne puissance
colonisatrice un terreau fertile pour
implanter de nouvelles idées
financé par les russes et par le
gouvernement trésor et ses camarades
organisent des rassemblements en soutien
à moscou
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
moi ce que la puce a fait chez nous on
n'a pas besoin de faire
le discours pro russe est bien rodée et
les éléments de langage affûté en main
en outre drapeau tricolore qui remplace
celui des français
dans l'histoire
appelle l'histoire témoin que la russie
n'a jamais brisé un pays africain nous
on n'est pas contre la france mais c'est
la mauvaise politique de la france qui
nous fait qu'il nous fait du mal nous
avons fait combien d'années avec la
france regardez l'état de pays nous
avons qu'on nous promet du coup d'état
nous savons qu'on nous promet de me
tenir et on a perdu chrome et du présent
de l'afrique sympathique aujourd'hui
avec la présence russe dans un laps de
temps nous avons un bon résultat et ça
m'a poussé ça m'a donné un engagement
ferme à cette nuit là aussi parce que
c'est qu'on veut c'est le bien-être non
libre ciculation effet aujourd'hui si on
a la sécurité les jeunes peuvent aller à
l'école nous avons peuvent aller étudier
et ça nous le voyons tous les homos
c'est pourquoi ça m'a donné le courage
et l'envié de tenir le drapeau russe
pour dire merci à la russie mais sous
prison pour rien
[Musique]
les discours pro russe se mêlent aux
arguments contre une france en perte d'
influence
en vide rapidement comblé par moscou
la bière locale propriété d'un groupe
français est la boisson la plus prisée
des centrafricains
mais elle fait maintenant face à un
nouveau concurrent
la russie étant son emprise jusque dans
les bars de la capitale avec la toute
première vodka commercialisée en
centrafrique fabriqué par une société
proche elle aussi des mercenaires russes
nab et afrique à la technologie shawish
samedi que fabriquer en rca bat écologie
russe se forment et sarah
c'est pas trop foncée forme mais ça va
ça ça donne de l'énergie
[Musique]
l'opération séduction s'affichait déjà
sur grand écran 2021
à bangui pendant une semaine des
milliers de personnes ont pu assister à
la grande première de touristes en film
d'action russe tourné en centrafrique
le film est produit par une société de
la galaxie wagner et raconte
l'intervention des mercenaires dans le
pays
on y trouve tous les codes d'un
blockbuster américain
à quelques détails près
mais cannes ce chalet
jouais
bien je te laisse
trop de déchet lestonan ce bout de film
et qu'il me dise pas cet avis
vous n'êtes pas minimes ont gravi qui
aiment ce qui est c'est fait aussi chaud
pour dire je vaux et réalise nous avons
décidé que notre fille sera en tant que
réel basé sur des faits réels sur la vue
réelle des scènes d'action de ce qui se
passe en réalité
wagner déploie les grands moyens pour
faire de la centrafrique une vitrine de
son intervention
professionnelle l'objectif sonne comme
une vieille rengaine conquérir les
coeurs et gagner les esprits
vous
alors quels sont les bons
avec les lutteurs elle je me revoilà un
peu dans mon jeu d'acteur comment j'ai
assuré cité mélo un jeune acteur a
décroché l'un des rôles principaux dans
touristes le rôle d'une vie dans ce film
de propagande il interprète l'ennemi des
russes
ce ne sont pas ces gens de nouvelles que
moi je voudrais entendre avez vous
compris
et voilà je pense qu'il est mieux pour
vous de quitter le pays pour votre
sécurité
garde allons-y
allons-y
une opportunité unique mais en pari
risqué pour mélo interpréter l'ancien
président bozizé devenu chef rebelle et
ennemi public en centrafrique ce n'est
pas sans risque ici je pense que quand
j'ai eu comme j'ai opposé supposé il n'y
a pas de photos entre - ce gars là je
fais mon travail je n'ai rien à voir
avec les russes qu'ils arrivent mais les
russes ils ont besoin des acteurs des
bons acteurs et voilà moi j'ai fait mon
travail eh bien il ya un malade qui
compromet en rien qui dit toi tu avais
de bozizé et qui vient me planter un
plomb dans la tête passait au mip en ce
moment je suis un gars de bozizé ma
famille va tu vois ma mère en colle à
mes enfants toute ma famille qu'est-ce
que je les y ai je me prends toi je n'ai
pas un canapé je n'ai rien
dans un pays sans industrie du cinéma
difficile d'être comédien
[Musique]
mélo rêvait d'une carrière
internationale qui changerait sa vie et
celle de sa famille
tu vois ma famille voilà je n'ai rien de
de quelqu'un qui a joué dans un film de
de grande instance est un film qui a
fait un carton en république
centrafricaine normalement si c'est
ailleurs qu'il voit tout de suite je
serai en train de rouler grosse caisse
peut-être en train de construire une
nouvelle villa pour moi mes enfants bien
tu vois dans quel confort je travaille
je parle pas de confort mathieu voir moi
dans la nuit le travail
[Applaudissements]
pourtant en an plus tôt mélo foulé le
tapis rouge devant une foule en liesse
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les affiches on pallie les
gradins sont vides et mélo se sont pris
dans un conflit qui le dépasse
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est la guerre des médias
c'est la guerre de communication et donc
chacun essaie de idées de sorties son
armada le pays le plus grand possible se
confiera il ya beaucoup d'angles ne se
confient mais les reçu 1 n'ont pris
qu'une partie infime de ce conflit là
ils ont juste pris ce qui les concerne
mais il ya beaucoup d'en dessous
[Musique]
ce qui n'apparaît pas dans le film et
que la propagande évite soigneusement de
mentionner ce sont les victimes des
mercenaires
tortures viols meurtres pillages et
autres crimes de guerre
les russes sont accusées de centaines
d'exactions par les nations unies des
associations locales comme celle d'ali
ousmane prockl discrètement des
témoignages dans le quartier musulman de
bangui
je
là il a 25 ans elle est la veuve d'un
négociant d'or et de diamants dans le
centre du pays son mari a été tué par
une patrouille militaire commandé par
les russes
mon mari voyageait entre les mines d'or
et de diamant pour les revendre dans la
ville de bambari
un jour j'ai appris que des militaires
menaient une opération sur cette route
gelée prévenu mais il a pris le risque
malgré tout
il n'avait rien à se reprocher et
voulait me rejoindre mois et les enfants
les militaires l'ont arrêté
ils ont volé ces diamants sont hors des
cadeaux pour les enfants
ils ont d'abord essayé de le tuer avec
un fusil
et larmes s'est enrayée
alors ils l'ont ligoté avant de le
poignarder avec un couteau
les mercenaires russes sont par des
sites miniers pour vendre l'or et les
diamants ils sont engagés dans une
perpétuelle bataille avec les rebelles
dont les finances repose également sur
la vente de minerais
les populations ne sont pas épargnés
[Musique]
et c'est là ce n'est même pas prédéfinis
ça ne fait que s'accentuer
[Musique]
des histoires comme celle de leïla il en
existe des milliers la plupart étouffés
par la crainte des représailles
les communautés musulmanes epl sont
particulièrement ciblés par les forces
armées dans l'arrière-pays
les mercenaires les associer aux
rebelles des milliers d'entre eux fuient
les violences et la persécution
la plupart s'installent dans ce quartier
avec une peur des russes
sur le terrain on n'a pas vu ce que
c'était la version officielle qui est
venu mais c'est la vie c'est officiel
par l'entremise des entreprises
militaires qu'elles ont le coeur à
glaire si le moment venu il avait chassé
c'est lé bella mais il ne veut pas
libérer mais c'est sur nous qu'il faut
toutes les exactions sait déjà qu'ils
sont seuls loi ni foi et c'est ce que
nous dénonçons
ali osman est l'un des rares à oser
s'exprimer à visage découvert à
l'arrivée des russes les voix
discordantes ont été réduites au silence
la contradiction n'est plus toléré
surtout dans le quartier du président
ou dès leur plus jeune âge les enfants
apprennent à chanter les louanges des
mercenaires
[Musique]
l'auteur de cette comptine est un
puissant ministre le conseiller spécial
du président de la république
c'est politique un autre niveau et ses
éducateurs
l'appel à des gens qui aiment protéger
les plus faibles et tant pis faut qu'ils
aient ça dans leur mémoire
et peu importe les multiples enquêtes
internationales qui documente les
massacres de civils et pointe la
responsabilité des mercenaires russes
il n'y a pas de respect des droits
humains donc en les anéantit de manière
brutale et même de manière sauvage c'est
proportionnel à ce que font ces rebelles
à qui brûlent les maisons qui vole le
bétail chez nous il n'y a pas de
prisonniers il faut les anéantir passive
en deux ans
[Musique]
moscou a longtemps nié l'existence de
wagner en russie le mercenariat et
illégale
mais aujourd'hui pour la première fois
le gouvernement centrafricain reconnaît
leur présence et wagner sort de l'ombre
[Musique]
ah ah
nous avons signé avec la fédération de
russie si poutine président chef
commandeur en chef suprême des forces
armées russes nous envoie des wagner
ce n'est pas notre problème pour nous
c'est des russes et par le russe ils
viennent nous aider dans le cadre de
cette coopération qui s'appelle russe
qui s'appelle
beethoven ou mozart ils sont là pour
défendre la démocratie
centrafricaine et on les accepte on
aimerait bien recevoir les légionnaires
français
les mercenaires français où les
mercenaires américains comme on a vu en
irak pour venir nous soulager nous il
n'y a pas de problème on fait avec on ne
sait pas on va pas choisir la couleur de
l'eau pour éteindre le feu qui est dans
notre pays et donc des russes sont venus
nous ont envoyé c'est ses forces russes
que vous appelez wagner pour nous il n'y
a pas de problème et je n'ai pas honte
de porter ce t-shirt et des cuissons
[Musique]
le recours aux mercenaires est assumée
mais il n'est pas gratuit
joseph bendounga est l'un des seuls
parlementaires a dénoncé la mainmise des
russes sur les ressources de son pays
les russes sont venus puisque c'est eux
qui ont sauvé le pouvoir touadéra ils
ont imposé nous prenons tellement nous
exploiterons telle mine nous
exploiterons termine et ils l'ont fait
au vu et au su de tout le monde
aujourd'hui qui ceux qui contrôlent ces
exploitations minières tenus par les
russes personnes il ne rend compte à
personne qu'est-ce qu'ils emportent ce
sont les richesses la république
centrafricaine ce que la communauté
internationale est en train de faire
actuellement en faveur de l'ukraine il
faut qu'elles le fassent en faveur de la
république centrafricaine parce que les
russes sont venus attaquer et l'ukraine
détruire
l'ukraine clie l'ukraine et c'est la
même chose que les russes font pour la
république centrafricaine
cet éternel militants de l'opposition a
été plusieurs fois emprisonné dans sa
vie mais il ne baisse pas les bras
2 les centrafricains sont très
intelligents les centrafricains asept
tour maintenant et lorsqu'ils commencent
à décortiquer vous allez voir que le
centrafricain saura faire le jeu ce
milieu des choses est tranché dans le
sens de ses intérêts et ce moment là
lorsqu'il viendra je pense que les
russes eux mêmes selon que leur place
n'est plus dans le public sont
officielles
[Musique]
en attendant les mercenaires russes sont
toujours bien présents plus que jamais
au coeur du pouvoir pour défendre les
gouvernements qui serve leurs intérêts
le modèle séduit les régimes
autoritaires en afrique et wagner étend
son emprise
[Musique]